la parole le cas monsieur martial
saddier merci merci monsieur le
président ma question s'adresse à
monsieur le premier ministre
depuis plusieurs années le gouvernement
envoie des signaux négatifs à l'égard
des pôles de compétitivité
j'en veux pour preuve la réforme des
pôles annoncé le 4 janvier 2016 par
monsieur emmanuel macron à l'époque
ministre de l'économie de l'industrie du
numérique dès mars 2016 cette réforme
devrait débuter par une évaluation
individuelle des 71 pôles sans pour
autant qu'à ce jour nous sachions où
nous en sommes réellement
j'ai déjà eu l'occasion d'interroger le
gouvernement à ce sujet le 18 mai 2016
dans sa réponse
écoutez bien mes chers collègues
emmanuel macron avait indiqué je cite
aucun pôles de compétitivité ne sera
supprimé notre intention est tout au
plus de déléguer leur gestion et leur
animation région avec les crédits
afférents
comme j'ai eu l'occasion de le dire il
ya quelques semaines lorsque avec jean
michel baylet nous avons annoncé cette
initiative
il s'agit d'organiser ces pôles sur le
territoire de façon que neuf ou dix
d'entre eux soient coordonnés par l'état
depuis ces effet d'annonce aucune
stratégie n'a été arrêté par l'état et
aucun nouveau crédit de financement
spécifique contrairement à ce qu était l
scène a été transféré aux nouvelles
régions depuis le 1er janvier 2017 ce
sont donc ces nouvelles régions qui
doivent faire face seule à ce
désengagement total de l'état quant à la
question du financement de ces
structures qui sont pourtant le coeur de
l'économie demain monsieur le premier
push vous nous indiquer quelles
solutions votre majorité compte mettre
en oeuvre pour assurer la pérennité
financière de ces pôles je ne cache pas
que l'absence de lisibilité politique
vis à vis de ces structures nous
inquiète énormément de la même manière
la question est posée elle aussi
toujours sans réponse de l'extension
territoriale des pôles de compétitivité
au périmètre des nouvelles régions c'est
un sujet pour tous les pôles qui se
retrouvent à cheval sur plusieurs
régions compte tenu du périmètre des
nouvelles régions pouvez-vous là aussi
nous préciser quelle est votre vision
politique vis-à-vis de ces structures et
nous rassurer quant à votre soutien en
faveur de l'emploi de l'industrie et du
développement économique
si la parole est à monsieur le
secrétaire d'état chargé de l'industrie
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les députés
monsieur le député martial saddier je
veux d'abord dire très clairement au nom
du gouvernement que nous saluons le
travail exercé par les différents pôles
de compétitivité et que de ce point de
vue il y à une reconnaissance sur le
rôle qu'il joue dans un écosystème
permettant au travers de l'innovation et
de la recherche de porter des enjeux de
production qui sont aussi des enjeux
particulièrement important nous avons
voulu à partir de 2013 relancer les
enjeux d'innovation et nous avons
demandé à france stratégie d' évaluer
les dispositifs en place
c'était 27 évaluations montrent la
pertinence de l'engagement public dans
les pôles de compétitivité puisque un
héros engagé un euro engagée par le
public justifie 2 euros engagés par les
entreprises et donc l'effet levier qui
est ainsi constaté est un élément
extrêmement positif mais la même étude a
pu montrer qu'il y avait à la fois pour
ses pôles de compétitivité une
multiplicité des fonctions qui leur sont
demandées on leur demande d'être dans
l'innovation dans la recherche mais
elles font aussi de l'accompagnement
d'entreprises mais elles font aussi de
la recherche en financement mais elles
font aussi de la recherche à l'internât
site de l'accompagnement à
l'international
ce sont ces éléments qu'il nous faut
prendre en compte que nous donne l'étude
de france stratégie et ces éléments
doivent nous permettre une réflexion
engagée avec l'association des régions
de france puisque j'ai rencontré le
président de l'association des régions
de france sur lez lille équilibre entre
la participation de l'état et celle des
régions je m'étonne toujours qu' on
puisse avoir des régions qui nous
explique que dans cette discussion qui
amènera à savoir de quel niveau relève
ses pôles de compétitivité lorsqu'ils
envisagent d'être confiés à des régions
ils seraient moins pertinent moins forts
que lorsqu'ils sont portés par le niveau
national ce que je crois important c'est
que nous puissions à la fois nous
mobiliser pour les accompagner nous
mobiliser pour leur permettre de réussir
et nous mobiliser pour faire que ces
pôles de compétitivité perdure c'est
notre volonté en tout cas merci monsieur
sirugue la séance des questions